[Music]
ladies on the one and only country pop
megastar Shania Twain you have the first
ever fifth chair on the voice how cool
is that it's way cool it's amazing I'm
I'm on top of the world
Wow Lee Shania Twain goodness
everybody's made me feel at home first
of all the contestants have been so
gracious and then the coaches themselves
have been just very warm and welcoming I
think the only person that I'd never not
was Blake she's crazy to marry soon well
what did you think of Blake the first
time you met him you know he he's just
really sweet and kind and he was very
nurturing and caring and welcoming to me
so he's a gentleman
yeah yeah yeah and he's very funny he
started being noisy how funny yeah and
he knows all my songs of course he knows
all your songs just Shania Twain did you
like that better I'd I do Shania Twain
likes that I was waiting for you to just
say that don't trust me much how excited
are you for tonight though I'm after
we're all by its Alex button uh how much
fun did you have with her Glenn I am an
amazing Chuck I've been also since like
when I found out you were coming I had
an amazing time going back and like
listening to all the songs and googling
you and like the whole thing and then
then getting to know you a little bit
and then working together and then
googling you again and even learning
more like it was just a but it's been
Shania week for me your favorite song my
favorite song is I'm still the one but I
already told you that you did so it's
like that weird night yeah
[Music]
I'm so glad we made
[Music]